bienvenue nous sommes le 22 mars 1978 il
ya fort longtemps
certains d'entre vous n'étaient pas
encore nés il ya deux hommes qui
déjeunent à fanons pas au sud de l'île
la sauvegarde du nord qui est une
association qui existe toujours
aujourd'hui qui s'occupe de jeunes qui
ont été placés par les juges pour
enfants parce que leur famille n'étaient
pas en capacité d élever cette
association doit créer une école
hôtelière dans son centre
d'apprentissage il faut faire des
travaux
les deux hommes sont pierre de
saintignon qui à l'époque était le
directeur de l'association et rené du
tilleul qui est le fils du fondateur du
groupe éponyme rabot dutilleul un groupe
de bâtiment et travaux publics qui est
très connu mais tant dans la région qui
a beaucoup prospéré et pierre dia rhône
et le la prochaine fois que nous ferons
des travaux ensemble
soyez aimable mettez moi un chef
d'equipe et je vous fournirai trop
quatre jeunes voyous que j'ai dans mes
foyer
l'histoire aurait pu s'arrêter là mais
voilà à la fin du repas rené du tilleul
qui est toujours en vie aujourd'hui
lui lance et vos jeunes ou les avez là
sous la main pourquoi eh ben ils vont
commencer tout de suite et quatre jeunes
un peu dur c'est ma qu'on puisse dire on
fait le boulot ne sont pas fait dans la
dentelle
ils ont repeint et puis quand tout a été
terminé
ils ont authentiquement balancer la
peinture partout sur les murs c'est ce
jour là mesdames messieurs qui est des
vite habilité t comme travail et qui
depuis 40 ans est devenue une grande
entreprise sociale et solidaire
qui accueilli près de quarante mille
hommes et femmes en difficulté et qui a
essayé d'affranchir la frontière ténue
entre la question sociale et la question
économique marque
je vous présente marque qui est un des
jeunes peintres que je vais vous évoquez
à l'époque tu avais 17 ans et demi il
avait été retiré ce gamin par les
services sociaux à sa famille
placé dans un foyer chez vitamine t il
était temps en galère ils étaient en
échec
il avait mis ses profs en échec il en
voulait au monde entier il faisait des
conneries à droite à gauche c'est encore
un peu léger mais il était vraiment sur
la cour de rennes marque il avait besoin
dans l'apprentissage
il avait un cadre il a besoin d'une
figure paternelle d'une autorité
il avait surtout besoin de bosser c'est
pour marquer lisandro kravitz habilité
et plein d'autres encore il faut se
souvenir de ces années 80 où je vous
emmène depuis tout à l'heure nous sommes
juste après les trente glorieuses dans
ce pays
nous sommes juste après pour le premier
choc pétrolier
la france découvre le chômage de masse
la désindustrialisation galope des pans
entiers de notre économie s'effondre
c'est le début de la crise qui n'en
finit pas du ray nous y reviendrons tout
à l'heure et donc pour ces gamins en
souffrance déjà exposé fragile de
vitalité à l'époque il fallait que nous
les éducateurs dont j'étais les
travailleurs sociaux nous inventions de
nouvelles réponses nous cassions les
ligues location les codes entre le tout
social et le tout économique
il a fallu d'abord convaincre les
éducateurs dans ce monde aux gt2 cheveux
longs et de ponchos qui grattent le mot
entreprise était un gros mot peut être
encore est aujourd'hui était un
sacrilège
le capitaliste c'était l'ennemi et donc
c'était très difficile
de nous initier au budget prévisionnel
au compte d'exploitation à la relation
client au benchmark que sais-je encore
il ya eu des grèves à l'époque je me
souviens chez certains éducateurs
mais je ne leur en veux pas avec le
temps qui a passé je la regarde toute
mon affection
il a fallu aussi convaincre les pouvoirs
publics
il était à la ramasse puisque les
premières salves de chômage de longue
durée commencé à arriver et il fallait
surtout convaincre les milieux
économiques qui j'en suis convaincue
quarante ans plus tard nous prenez assez
probablement pour des gentils ancêtres
de nuit debout et bien contre toute
attente c'est rené dutilleul d'autres
encore
ils ont été au rendez vous et ils nous
ont prêté une oreille attentive
on se gausse dans notre région parfois
de ce patronat un peu chrétien un peu
sociale
mais moi je me souviens qu'ils ont été
là des premiers jours et qui lui ont
fait confiance pour changer la vie de
ces milliers de jeunes et de moins
jeunes à son rôle à cette époque
incroyable mais vraiment incroyable dont
je suis nostalgique avec vous qui est
celle du bouillonnement on a ici la
lombriculture dans l'est dans les
flandres les panneaux solaires avant
l'heure ce n'est pas de soleil et je
n'ai pas de clients
on a les oranges des fameuses oranges
qui ont donné leur nom d'ailleurs un
vitamine t elle était sur le à deux pas
d'ici
sur la grand place de lille et nous
avions des jeunes qui vendait des jus
pressé en distribuant leurs cv
d'ailleurs vous avez retrouvé le punch
aux dents dans la bulle mais aussi les
petites modèles d'avions convaincu des
retraités de la banque de france de
trier avec nos jeunes de la petite
monnaie dans les aéroports pour monter
des projets d'insertion une époque donc
incroyable de bouillonnement
d'innovation sociale et économique
certaines de ces idées d'ailleurs sont
devenus au jour à ce moment là et
toujours aujourd'hui des entreprises aux
salles vitalité
elles ont même beaucoup prospéré elle
compte plusieurs centaines de salariés
d'autres de ces idées ont vécu leur
cycle de vie normale elles sont les
entreprises ont été créées
puis elles se sont éteintes et remplacés
par d'autres d'autres idées enfin n'ont
jamais abouti mais quelle époque encore
une fois de bouillonnement et
d'innovation c'est à ce moment là que
moi éducateurs
j'arrive à vitalité je connais bien ces
jeunes puisque moi-même je travaillais
que des gamins qu'on appelle sous main
de justice et puissant surtout faire
pleurer dans les chaumières
j'aurais pu être moi même un de ses
enfants pour retrouver un jour dans nos
entreprises d'insertion que j'étais de
la dass
j'avais le goût des autres savent a
envie de réussir ma vie plus que de
réussir dans ma vie j'avais l'obsession
de mettre cette ville sous contrainte
entre l'idéal et la réalité et surtout
je croyais plus à l'opérationnel qu'au
plan stratégique
allez michel je vous le présente des
portraits vrai authentique qui ont
marqué à vie michel ya 47 ans à cette
époque on est au début des années 90 il
n'a connu qu'un seul employeur il a été
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient été licenciés
pour motif économique de lucie textile
de roubaix qui l'employait il ne s'en
est jamais vraiment remis la famille a
vacillé il a perdu confiance en lui
cette qualification était obsolète
mélissa plutôt une gamine pourtant issus
de classes moyennes qui a sombré dans
l'addiction et qui de curan soins en
postcure a essayé et continueront
toujours de retricoter sa vie c'est pour
ces hommes et ces femmes que nous avons
fait bouger ces lignes
allez transportons-nous dans les années
2000 nous étions évidemment convaincu
comme vous j'imagine que le chômage ne
l'est pas duré que tous allaient assez
allait s'arrêter que c'était un mauvais
film et qu'on a le résultat aujourd'hui
c'est toujours le tsunami
alors nous avons décidé de changer
d'échelle c'est-à-dire de vraiment
devenir une entreprise certes sociale
mais qui se développe et qui puisse de
plus en plus répondre aux besoins
sociaux que j'évoquais pour ça quels ont
été les recettes parce que ça a été
vraiment un succès vraiment un succès
première recette s'affranchir de
l'argent public l'argent public ne peut
pas tout focaliser sur le marché
cherchait pour notre objet social
les moyens de notre performance
professionnaliser nos équipes
moi je recruter que des éducateurs
j'étais bien avec eux ou versailles à
lille le soir à refaire le monde mais il
fallait que je monte en compétences pour
faire du reporting pour faire du
contrôle de gestion pour aller chercher
avec nos dents les marchés et puis le
plus difficile et pour tout vous dire la
plus grande fierté collective
nous voulions du capital mais ne
voulions pas l'actionnaire
il ya un petit souci est donc trouver
les actionnaires trouver les capitales
mais qui tous les matins ne m'appelle
pas pour me demander le cours de
l'action
enfin et surtout recettes absolue de
cette success story c'est veiller à ce
que pour chaque homme et femme qui nous
rejoignent qu'il y ait un accompagnement
personnel intime extrêmement fort
extrêmement chaleureux les seuls
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes en 90 nous
avions 70% subventions et 30% ca en 2016
nous avons 80 7% chiffre d'affaires et
13 % de subventions en 90 nous avions
160 salariés à l'heure où je vous parle
chaque jour amid invités il y en a 1000
ce changement enfin d'échelle il a été
permis cette croissance incroyable a été
permis par une histoire il y a dix ans
quasiment jour pour jour comme on n'en
connaît qu'une fois dans sa vie nous
sommes à l'écart à deux pas d'ici là
thomson qui était l'une des plus grandes
entreprises électroménager
de france a fermé définitivement ses
portes
il restait 130 seniors en plan social en
licenciement et nous avons repris cette
usine pour en faire une superbe
d'entreprises de traitement de déchets
d'équipements électriques et
électroniques envie de ce qui
aujourd'hui est leader dans son domaine
qui vient de remporter des marchés pour
48 millions d'euros pour les années qui
viennent et qui chaque année recrute 200
à 250 salariés
c'est le genre d' aventure industrielle
économique écologique et social qui a
permis de changer d'échelle nous avons
eu est évidemment également des échecs
nous avons appris de ses échecs là
notamment avec maxime holder le fils du
fondateur de paul les boulangeries paul
où il avait des jeunes
il voulait informer comme boulanger et
nous nous avions des jeunes dans le
pétrin si je peux dire que nous
pourrions remettre au bon sens du terme
dans le pétrin nous avons créé une gamme
de recettes nous avons ouvert une
boulangerie à lille wazemmes
arusha et nous nous sommes plantés
lamentablement
nous avons pour hâter la gamme de
produits qu'il plaisait pas aux bilans
l'insertion des jeunes
la compétence d'achat et caetera et donc
nous avons dû fermer très rapidement et
nous avons aussi appris de ses échecs
allez je termine pour quand vous
présentons trois miracles zima trois
miracles humain c'est annie il était
mineur il ya quatre ans dans la jungle
de calais nous la voie que dit dans une
de nos structures à grande synthe dans
une structure de maraîchage il a appris
parfaitement le français
il a trouvé vrai de vrai il a passé un
permis poids lourds pardon il a trouvé
un cdd de poids lourds dans une
entreprise de dakar avec une promesse de
ce deal si tout va bien j'ai dit un lit
je suis sûr que samedi après-midi avec
votre énergie là bien que tu auras tour
ces lignes c'est vanessa qui a une
histoire absolument épouvantable qui est
tombée cette fois qui servait vite qu'à
passer ya quelques mois à saper une
petite enfance et qui a trouvé un cdi en
crèche
c'est enfin john non son spécial pour
toi mon cher john que je croise tous les
matins sur notre site qui est arrivé
dans des conditions aussi très difficile
de l'entreprise de déchets
qui as est alphabétisée s'est battu ces
relevés a passé son cas c'est ce a été
embauchée cher non pas le place dans une
emprise de plasturgie
oui et en cdi et tous les matins quand
je vois son visage arrivant au travail
je me dis que pour lui vitamine t as
raison d'exister alors je suis comme
martin luther king et comme vous j'ai
quelques rêves mary jane c'est d'une
part que les pouvoirs publics quels
qu'ils soient s'inspire de cette réponse
moderne entre le tout sociale elle tout
économique
c'est que les jeunes de centrale lille
ou de l'edhec plutôt que d'aller tout de
suite chez l'oréal ou chez danone ou
trader à la city passe d'abord chez nous
dans une entreprise sociale c'est que
les entreprises dites la ci puissent
s'inspirer de nos pratiques pour
développer leur impact social je vous
remercie beaucoup